isn't that [ __ ] what company was it
wasn't Nestle I hope I'm not like it was
it label if I say [ __ ] that's not right
real I think it is a libelous [ __ ] all
the time no but but the whole you know
my brain is not working
uh the water let's come back to this
Nestle and water
Bailey being a [ __ ] boy with the whole
Flint thing there we go um yeah so
man I'm telling this story so badly but
apparently Flint or Michigan or wherever
the government there has a deal with
Nestle and the Nestle started charging
people for water after X amount of
really min passed and it's like you're
not even giving us like access to
drinkable water and you're charging us
for water now is that flip one of the
things still at issue right now yeah I
mean they don't trust the people that I
don't trust the government and how why
am I supposed to trust you
how come they don't have water what so
what's the issue it's not a bit they
have water but the pipes so they didn't
either update the pipes or they didn't
take care to filter the water that is
going to the people and so it had really
high concentrations of contaminants yeah
yeah and I think you're literally
killing your population that's crazy
good what are the most like I guess like
technology technologically advanced or
just we're supposed to be like a shining
light first world and yeah we can't even
get water to be it's ridiculous and I
think about it's kind of like Flint New
Orleans what's in common
black people let's be honest because if
there's a whole bunch of white people
there you think that would have happened
like what yo did you hear about the
whole issue with so target has his brand
called the honeypot I saw that you see
that you read the article I saw the
heading today but oh so I'm forgetting
her name but actually let me looked at
it because I want to give her some
[ __ ] credit but a honeypot is a sa
brand of like feminine care products
right and it's in his black-owned
specifically black female owned right
her name is Beatrice Dixon which is the
most non black name of my line that's
not like a whole white lady
as I let the folk sound like a 1920s old
white lady that's [ __ ] crazy but she
started up this uh this feminine Karen
line right and it does super well at
Target like people [ __ ] love it rave
reviews but she did a video where she
said let's see but it was something
along the lines and it was by the way
number one it was harmless and it
doesn't mean anything but people you
know how when you say something people
like to twist it but she says that you
know one of the she really appreciated
that Target picked up her brand because
it's great that they like young black
women can see that you could have a
successful business right it's great for
young black women to see and so for some
reason a bunch of why people took that
as oh I don't want to support this
racist product because it's apparently
is only for black people it's like yo
[ __ ] that's not what she [ __ ] said
like people this is all eyes mater crowd
its it's such a it was so and you know
at first you know sometimes like media
likes to exaggerate things right but
then people were giving cited examples
of these reviews and apparently like her
product originally on target had I may
fix the issue now it like it's all five
stars now so before it had five stars
but after people were upset about it
they put they were giving it one star
review saying that her comments were
super racist that it was it was very
unnecessary or some [ __ ] like that
people are really offended and then her
I think it went down like two stars or
some [ __ ] like that but it was so
ridiculous I'm like how did you take
that as that how is that an attack on
you how's that racist - exactly well
okay that's that's its own topic yeah
you want to unpack what even racism
means but it's like literally saying I
want to uplift my community means I'm
racist brah yeah cuz I I genuinely feel
let's say if that was like I don't know
like an Asian or Mexican person and they
said that like I created this because I
want my kids to know or you know like a
young Asian women to know that you know
you could have a business I don't think
anybody would have been like yo this is
a racist product because they only want
to put at Asian people I don't think
that would have been the case I really
don't because that's a very odd that's a
very odd take away from that statement
you know this climate the political
climate even though it feels like a
regression in some ways has been good
because it's kind of just open the
screen on everybody that you
was you know Wendy's like kumbaya a post
Obama like society it's like no the fact
that that's happening in this day and
age like it's like what but I love that
the end to that story the article I saw
at least was that her sales went all the
way up yeah cuz it was a few I think cuz
what happens is just like a few annoying
loud people don't represent a majority
of the community because you know if
people have like a certain I feel like
what happened was is that they bought
this product and they didn't know that a
black woman was running the company how
is it that you find out and you are so
heated by that like I refuse they just
took the tampon an octopus wing that
[ __ ] around it throw it out a [ __ ]
window I don't give a [ __ ] what I'm
Beatrice Dickson Beatrice that's
probably why sure I knew it because of
her name she I just longer unpacked the
mystery right now you should be a
detective I should do it like you're
Blue's Clues coward they heard the name
Beatrice Dixon and they were like she is
an old white racist lady and I support
her because she was gonna wear a t-shirt
with a confederate flag on it so weird
it was a weird move though for those few
people that that said that it was racist
that's a very weird thing to say I never
understand it like I'm like where are
you coming from
I mean part of me wants to interview
them yeah like sit them down it's like
well why do you think it's racist it's
big III guess what the what where I read
from the article and also what I'm
assuming is that when they heard that
they what they heard is this product is
only for black women and that's nowhere
near what she was saying which is such
an odd thing races races like the
hottest topic right right now especially
over on Twitter and it's it's weird
because I see I see it go to like the
extremes now I get and also to like the
most extreme cool are the most vocal
that's the thing I mean they everybody
here is I'm the most exactly so kind of
it kind of tastes things in a weird way
too I remember reading for you when we
had this conversation back in the day
like you were telling me like growing up
because you know you you know you came
here when you were 12 from Nigeria like
it was you it was either your parents or
you had a hard understanding of like
like black plight
like in the States because it wasn't
that your apartment I remember
conversations did people don't know I
listen - that's what she yeah